we got like I said 14 13 10. we're just
getting into those 10 years that's a
whole new roller coaster Matthew
McConaughey getting real about the ride
that is fatherhood well the whole
thing's pretty crazy the actor opening
up about his three kiddos 14 year old
Levi 13 year old Vita and today and Ted
Livingston
stand how they're not so little
Chelsea handlers podcast with the 14 and
13 I'm getting to that age where I'm
starting to become their buddy a little
bit which is cool meaning like my
daughter will call me over and go hey I
want to talk to you about this thing and
we can just talk where I'm not teaching
I'm not talking as the parent we're just
jiving or my son can go flipped on like
a NPR the other day and didn't want to
listen to music I want to listen to this
I'm like at 14 oh my God and what'd you
get out of this this talk he's listening
to podcasts and stuff I'm going okay
okay so I'm becoming buddies with the
older two right now which is nice yeah
while some parents might dread the teen
years Matthew's loving it what better
Legacy could we leave behind
than our children he and his wife
Camilla Alves are proud to watch their
mini-me's come into their own I noticed
early on that oh these these these young
people are who they are I can Shepherd
them I can nudge them I can put in front
of them what lights their fire and try
to keep them from hurting themselves too
bad but other than that they are who
they are we're filling their passports
which as you know I think is one of my
one of the best resumes someone can have
you see a full passport you got a pretty
good idea that that person has some
wisdom of how the world works and how
Humanity rolls and he's not shy about
giving himself a little parenting cred
and when you become a parent you have
other people that will not survive
without you my happiness that I think
it's going pretty well not making
Straight A's but I think it's going
pretty well I got some considerate
children hopefully they can get out of
the house confident having an idea of
who the hell they are and who they're
not
while the McConaughey kids have started
to live more more publicly they've
mostly stayed out of the spotlight but
seen or unseen Matthews always been a
proud papa you know you got one our
eldest is very clean very balanced our
middle girl is like very coordinated but
doesn't know where her right hand's
going and then there's the youngest one
who you have to wake up very differently
than the other two I mean we can greet
the day without coming out of Rage I've
got more street cred at the dinner table
now that I'm in in the sinks haven't
made me they can see so finally making
something they can see they dig them
they still they they know I made it but
yet when we got to the theater to watch
it and they see busterman come on voice
comes out think it sounds like their dad
they look over at me they look back at
the screen look over me look back at the
screen look over me black at the screen
then they get a big smile on their face
I've said this before but one having
children as you're reminded that's
really good for an adult my job is that
you're reminded to see everything for
the first time and you're raising them
and they're seeing things for the first
time and for us it's old hat I've walked
that path 200 times and they're like no
but what about this
um so that freshness in that innocence
is very good
[Music]
thank you